yeah welcome to this video I was trying
to get a 15 minute game but somehow it
didn't start so I pressed this 45-minute
game option again and got um a game
instantly seems that there are so few
people going for that that you already
get a game so I'm lighter 3 plate and
let's play let's play the Dutch I really
didn't do that too often ok played this
quickly now I have two basic options I
can got more than two but damn I could
play the the Leningrad with g6 or the
stone wall with e-cigs I have a bit of
experience with both but um not sure
what I should should do now okay let's
let's play the stone wall I feel more
confident with this with this setup and
he already has got the knight on f3 so
on some of the more threatening options
involve night h3 so this is already a
for faded um yeah normal would be c4 c6
and then why it has a choice of lines of
course we can also play for example
Bishop f4 now immediately okay ya b3 is
of course um a normal way to prepare the
the bishop development also Bishop e3
years some a possibility this is why I
play Queenie's haven't the queen is good
on is heaven anyway and this way I
prevent Bishop a 34 at least for one
move white can um pre
have this move further with a form and
then Bishop e3 okay I can I think just
just cancel keep it simple here see for
ya now I must play c6 I could try b6
intending to play this without them the
move c6 count okay let's let's play c6
complete the stone bomb yeah now bishop
to be to versa normal c5 is a bit
uncommon yeah okay I need to play Bishop
c7 anyway no other square it's a bit
uncommon to play c5 and the only idea of
c-5 would be to play be for a4 b5
checking on the queenside and this is um
yeah a bit slow doesn't really give
white much so one drawback of the c5
movements that i might play 'if I've at
some point I could play Knight B to D
seven and then if I've had some
difficult for him to prevent that if he
goes on night BTW 795 himself i could
take only five Knight to d7 and then e
five NC fiber saying so I'll void upon
and he cannot prevent d 5 so the only
question is do I really want to want to
play this the c5 move it's certainly not
bad this is so this is clear but um
another idea is to a general ideas if if
you look at the queenside it is fairly
closed and not easy
see how wide will open it even got the
night on d 2 so you cannot easily play
b4 b5 with the knight on c3 supporting
this move so one idea could be for black
to simply keep the center as it is and
not move anything there or and try to
attack on the King side I try I try that
I play Bishop d7 d8 first to age five
and then 97 and then maybe prepare some
action on the King side oh this was
quickly played yeah maybe he's some
pretty bad preparing 95 possible came
after this move he can play 95 I have
bishop age five though
n95 I'll go Bishop to age five and then
I'd be to d7 ok yeah maybe preparing b5
should I play Bishop h5 its own
certainly not bad making sure that I'll
get this Bishop exchange but it's not
such a bad piece anyway by now not sure
if I need to need to exchange it ok it's
so it's still on on a good post on h5
you still need some preparation to get
something going here on the queenside
yep enter let's complete development
here if you place 95 then there's even
no Bishop to e2 to consider not not as
an instant reply but the size is a
possibility so III yeah this move really
doesn't do much I mean a 4 I would have
would have understood some 194 maybe
it's only not bad centralized this piece
yeah the bad thing about this is we will
never be able to UM to capture on you
for some the move III has weakened the
light square so much this means that
this neither some constant verify we
cannot easily get rid of this piece
yes Allah think I'm white should try a
45 the only kind of play that he that
his God but he played a 3 last move so
the somme doesn't seem to be on on this
agenda Knight to e5 mmm yeah how to
proceed now yeah I could exchange all
nights that's the sum normally quite ok
for black in the stone wall I could do
that but dumb it might lead to a very
blocked position like 92 2295 de 5 and
then it will play a form and it's
totally blocked hmm yeah but difficult
too difficult to find something else I
wonder and wonder about 95 de 5 Bishop
e2 so maybe an idea and this way to
activate the bishop ok let's let's take
here first this is probably necessary
anyway and now Bishop e2 which should be
to Knight takes e4 Bishop takes f1 is
some probably Justin
just an exchange with not much
compensation myths can go nite gd6 but
erm yeah can't be too threatening so
let's set Bishop b2 rook to e1 night XD
to he takes on detail with the Queen I
can get the Bishop to c4 which is at
least outside the pawn chain and on c4
it also in connection with pawn to a6
would prevent is a4 b5 idea it's quite
annoying this piece in the middle of
whites camp zone this shouldn't be too
bad now the other idea Bishop e2 rookie
one night XD to look take see to then I
can numb to retreat the night to to c4
or two to e4 bag I go if I go to c4
actually there's a5 hanging I can play
f4 f4 then I could play the move from be
six maybe okay let's let's play this it
so at least them a bit bit of an
imbalance after this I could have taken
on d 2 with the night and it's probably
around equal this look looks a bit more
a bit more unbalanced this position or
let's say if he would take on d to like
rook f3 192 Queen d2 Bishop c4 and then
we have the same structure like the
immediate capture but at least i got my
bishop on on c4 which should be a bit
irritating frame
yeah considering the time um it's it's
almost the same pace as a 15 minute game
i would say it bit slower maybe but not
much of a difference people are seem to
play relatively relatively quickly still
I don't want to make the 45-minute games
a constant feature it sir some it's a
bit long it can get can get really long
those games but I didn't get a game in
15 minute for quite a while that didn't
feel much like I'm playing blitz ok
nitey for I am yeah I thought this
wouldn't be sufficient but ok I need to
take f1 no choice aha I didn't didn't
think about this at all interesting
hmm guy interesting move but ok he
cannot all right let let's consider this
it's at some point in not taking the
night King edge it yeah well I will take
next move anyway and it doesn't make
much sense to too late to delay this I
can yeah I can take with rook
theoretically but he takes f6 so yeah
I'm piece down right then yeah I need to
take with the poem hmm yeah I need to
take with the pond whatever um so now
you will take on f6 and so um ok he
wants to use the long diagonal but a
simple solution would be 27 probably it
takes on f1 with them with a bishop
probably and then then Bishop to d8
picking up they have six pawn yeah this
sir should be should be a simple
solution I could play equal to play
brook f6 also but I can take f6 and
Queen Elsa group takes everyone ok an
alternative here would be to play 'if
I've play 'if I've and then take the
porn on f6 it's not much he can do about
that as well but let's just let's just
get this pawn I'm not sure I want to
play if I
it's somewhat loosens the pawn structure
in the center it may be easier to just
get f6 and exchange the bishops on the
long diagonal then put the queen on g7
or f6 controlling that after that I
White has no play at all i think yes
ideas like f7 check and quincy three but
i always have bishop f6 in case of that
the NID f6 check and was not really
working i played this rather quickly not
not quite sure why i mean after Bishop
e2 we could have easily played rookie
one and was not much going on
yeah white is very little for the
exchange here the problem is some then I
don't really have any structural big big
structural problems I get this pawn he
cannot down protect it in any way and
the position is fairly closed um he
doesn't have any big instant ideas
against my king that can now use my
rooks later maybe in the long run
putting some rook on da play d4 open up
the center
ya know is spending lots of time I hope
he didn't decide to I ok but should be
true I hope he and I wanted to say is
then decide to simply let the clock run
down I wonder how how much time i would
need to wait to actually get the point i
hope not 15 minutes ok i grabbed
assembly grabbed upon him maybe i'm now
that i think of it maybe em some Queen
move and then taking now what's more
precise ok let's it's not not a big
issue ok Bishop Bishop between two g7
may be fighting for this long diagonal
Luke g6 some he's got something I can
wish of 85 yeah but this is truly a
threat right I want to get the Queen on
the long diagonal this would would help
I think I am ok let's go here mediately
intending rook to just drove f7 or oak
g6 with Queen soffits some simple
technical issue
they can try am 35 but just just rook
rook g6 rook h6 there's some not much
that you can do Queen d6 in this case
loses 35 the queen is trapped you cannot
really am enter my position with the
Queen
you know the idea could could be to play
rook to deform if I go group g6
something that you can play route deform
hmm yeah but let's say I play a play
look here look T for then I can play you
five and five is useful anyway
I went to h6 because root d45 row gauge
force not possible man okay he wants to
avoid the Queen trade understandably so
how do how to proceed from here if I can
take actually on on if I on f5 so I
cannot do that yeah what about Queen to
e5 centralizing simply yeah probably not
not bad but if I therefore would be on
something that looks reasonable yeah
maybe prepare this rook a fade but
rookie afraid you can probably play can
maybe play a form but f45 a five and
rookie six opening up against the pawn
yeah now I must must be fine really rock
f8 85
if 5 f-5 open up the position i'm trying
to use all all heavy pieces now yeah b5
the only counterplay possible but then
after the capture and play a 5 after
capturing here on c6 i can retake with
the pawn and the rukon age 6 is covering
the c6 porn so that looks like green a
form isn't really a threatening anything
it still will take quite a while until
you get nem any serious threat going b5
also means that his weekend to the c5
pond it's also important okay just look
here intending a move like Queen e7 to
increase the pressure against the e3
porn and this loose bishop on YouTube
maybe yeah but I was just thinking about
Queen a for checking 87 but I threatened
to take on a form I mean this is
something he needs to pay attention to
yep just recapture
yeah on a on a general note here about
this opening the stone wall um it's
quite a good opening actually four
blankets are a bit um underestimated
sometimes it isn't played on the on the
very highest level simply because people
are at the very top don't want to settle
himself with some structural weakness
from the get-go but black has some
compensation for those structural
deficits and the compensation is is
space blank Scott actually a space
advantage which is a rare feature and a
black opening and it also leads to a
very M strategical kind of game and this
can be um a good choice against on
people who are really am focused on
mainly on non-technical play so it's a
good opening against the technicians
okay Bishop d3 attacking f5 and so um
where I can take on her form and open
open up the position okay wait wait I
was just a little just thought that I
can take and play also go into em to
deform but it's just the check young
just risking king h1 or g2 and I don't
have a good continuation okay yeah I
think I'll played this one just just
this is a simple move it keeps my
structure intact f5 is not detect any
more and he has opened the B file and
well I've got rooks rooks belong on open
files and I can just play rugby 8 next
smooth intending
to put other rook on beach you are the
Queen on b2 and while the open file is
important that I'm the one with the two
rooks right only Scott one rook so my
next move is rugby 8 and then probably
am reroute the e6e six rook to e8 and
turn yeah getting all this on the B file
or rookie seven to be seven can be good
as well but first I need to occupy the B
file on rook be one um I can play em
just stroke eat we ate covering his some
got porn weaknesses on c5 and III and
this arm I even easier to attack then
then my weakness on c6 ya f five
assaults a week but this takes a while
to to attack
this is a past really passive move now
okay I'm so let's say rookie seven
threatening rook yeah okay this is mmm
ok now I've got time let's not play too
quickly
yeah i still like rookie 6237 best the
idea is rook b7 to be too so rugby 7s
really a big threat entering here and so
on rook 6 to 8 79 we probably must
consider Bishop a six but then apply
Queen a one check and take on a three
with the tempo to to a one take a three
with the tempo on the bishop so this
looks even better than playing rook
green a one immediately which is a good
move also Queen a one check some move
between a three grabbing the porn and
checking you three but I'd like to do
this with a tempo so um let's let's play
this first it's a good it's a good term
muth improving the rook you can play
Queen a for attacking the c6 pawn but
then I've got Queen c3 which is really
annoying attacking everything porn III
was check and the rook on d to NC 5 so
of course I'm Queen a 1 also was fine
but this looks them even more convincing
I think ok now this check and taking on
a three
yeah the stone wall is an interesting
opening especially if you we had to this
move on a night f 3 f 5 which is a
course I'm a little bit different from d
405 and it's it's it's especially
interesting if you play the French
defense so that you can start with D 46
on the first move and keeping options a
little bit open the stone wall
especially m gain some some
attractiveness if the night h3 option is
it's not possible anymore so let's say d
4 e 69 f 3 and then go to the stone wall
this is some quite good a good move
autumn yeah this position yep i'm not
sure what whiter should play here King
f2 maybe but our king g 2 okay come on I
grab this right there's no trick
attacking the the bishop now this was
the the idea of all this that I gained
the temple now on the bishop and if the
bishop bum retreats somewhere then um
yeah I can take you three simply there's
no one no big big issue with this just
take the pawn I could play rucas 7272 to
be seven rookie to be seven rugby to
salsa I think pretty convincing
technically he's got everything on the
second rank yeah this is probably easier
taking only three s not not bad of
course still getting on the
second-ranked assess is probably quicker
yeah we should resign okay I'll need to
just briefly replying you set them
thanks for the game basically yeah this
is some now I'm pretty simple I'll get
to i get to be two nite at six some
ultimately failed it that's simply not
good the sounds exchange sacrifice or
let's say the the idea connected with 94
i think here he should don't just play
rookie won something like this and then
my idea was to take on d to after Queen
d2 drop to c 41 SI for the bishop is a
bit better compared to age five I had
thought and it allows us to to block
along this diagonal so that he cannot
easily advance the Queen side and look
here I thought not see form and now I'm
attacking me five he can protect with
this and then I was considering a move
like b6 if I can play v6 play on the
queenside or b-five be 5a five it's very
blocked of course but I've got good
pieces my light squared Bishop is Sam is
gone and i have fun opportunities here
to block the Queen side and then switch
my attention to the King side which
five this is very often a really stupid
positioned for bishops that because it's
so blocked even the bishop on g2 is
often simply yeah biting on granite on
d5 it's not doing much so this should be
it should be quite okay I think white
should probably simply after look not
this after looking one maybe just
capture with the Queen Bishop c4 and
then play some some normal moves like
Bishop to d4 and maybe even bishop
everyone at some point it's really this
Bishop I mean this bishop wants you for
its tech technically and maybe the bad
bishop because pawns are on light
squares but it's outside of outside the
pawn chain and this Bishop on g2 is also
really stupid piece so maybe he should
even consider at some point to play be
sure to add to word to f1 yeah thanks
for watching another 45 minute game I
hope to get more 15-minute games in the
future thanks